good morning Hank it's Friday how to
week I've got to go to Chicago today but
on my way I'm going to answer the top 10
search queries on Google beginning with
the words how to okay first how to tie a
time but before we talk about how to tie
a time we got to talk about which tie
you're gonna tie in order to do that
Hank you have to ask yourself a question
is it Christmas if so you're gonna want
to go with your Christmas tie and if not
you're still going to want to go with
your Christmas tie because we don't
actually know when Jesus was born ok
Hank so once you've chosen a suitably
understated dress shirt for your tie
make sure the little guy is shorter than
the big guy put the big guy over the
little guy for the big guy under the
little guy pull the big guy around keep
the fingers right here please and then
up and under and then right now this is
where this is where the magic happens
Hank you've got to find a way to put the
big guy right there in the hole I know
that's what she said then you pull down
mmm shape it shape it with the fingers
tug and now I am ready to learn how to
kiss you want to know how to kiss all
right first thing you need to do is get
a haircut because you're not Tony Danza
and this isn't who's the boss so Hank
broadly speaking there are three
approaches to kissing there's the fish
there's the slightly stupid person and
then there's the snake that dislocates
its jaw and eats its prey whole hmm I
fogged up the camera with my joke here's
how to kiss don't be the snake Hank I
would argue that ideally you want to be
situated somewhere between the fish and
the stupid person all right what's next
how do we weight fast
well I found that it's helpful when
someone puts your face on this t-shirt
bank in the last year I've lost 30
pounds on a very simple color-coded diet
I eat less brown stuff and more green
stuff next how to get pregnant you know
I don't know for something that 14 year
old to do all the time it sure is hard
for a lot of people but remember that
90% of couples conceive within their
first year of trying so just keep
banging away at it wait that pronoun has
an ambiguous antecedent what do I need
to keep banging away at the problem of
being difficult to connect topic how to
solve a Rubik's Cube fine but before we
solve a Rubik's Cube we need to learn
how to
spell Rubik's cube it's not are you bi X
it's are you bi K apostrophe s it is the
cube belonging to Rubik specifically
Erno Rubik the hungarian architecture
professor who invented rubik's cube
fortunately this topic has been covered
on YouTube click on the cube and it'll
take you to a video explaining in great
detail how to solve a Rubik's Cube
onward how to get a girl to like you I
have two recommendations for how to get
girls to like you number one you can
turn into a sneezy panda or number two
you can click on my face right now to be
taken to a video where I talk about that
very topic okay what's next how to make
it in America is a show on HBO
How to Train Your Dragon what you got to
realize is that the way you imagine your
enemy is often the way your enemy
imagines you also they like fish just
FYI how to make a website Thank You
already did that that's what led to how
to week click on my face to be taken to
Hanks video about how to make a website
and lastly how to write a resume Hank I
haven't done that in many years but I
have two tips 1 keep it to a page and 2
don't lie so that's how to do the top 10
things the people want to know how to do
on Google Hank I'll see you on Monday